you may already know that i'm a doctor
but what i really want to be
is a shark
the doctor shark is here be a wolf
esowatches is a silicone watch company
focused on
fashionable designs infused with
negative ion technology
i love mark cuban's face right away when
we start off the guy already knows it's
bs he's like i'm not falling for it
there's silicone in this there's ions
every day
our bodies are bombarded by positive
ions which are molecules
every day our bodies are bombarded with
molecules
yeah like water molecules like when you
take a shower every day when you wake up
you're bombarded by molecules i'm
talking about air and then you get into
the shower and you're bombarded by more
molecules and that's what computers tvs
fluorescent lighting
too much positive ion on our bodies puts
unnatural pressure on us so things that
exist in the environment naturally
causing pressure on us is unnatural
it sounds a little you know fluffy
well it sounds a lot like a coffee enema
you're trying to create a solution for a
non-existent problem
and that just fails at the outset thank
you very much
no thanks go ahead you keep it it's
dallas mavericks blue just for you okay
you keep it
okay thank you oh mark savage mark are
you allergic to positive negative ions
no i'm allergic to scams oh it's a joke
it's a scam it's not real i'm out
mark i'm with you the shark varshavsky
is out
syndevor labs designs and builds the
world's most sophisticated synthetic
human tissues and body parts
made from salt water and fiber just like
you and i
our products employ materials that mimic
the properties of human tissue
these products are used throughout the
medical industry
to replace live animals human cadavers
and even human patients in trauma
training surgical education
and medical device development i have
probably used one of these devices
and had no idea was made by this
gentleman or his company this is about
85
water by mass it has every muscle bone
and organ
in natural human anatomy it almost feels
like chicken raw chicken
it feels exactly like live tissue i love
that instead of saying it feels like a
human she said chicken
spent about 20 years doing the
development of the tissues itself he's
really sweaty and how do you do surgery
on it can you cut it
you can cut it it's uh basically a big
3d jigsaw
wow it's a brand new system wow he's
sweating
bullets what's the price point compared
to a cadaver
it costs a lot more uh connectivity
because this is reusable
right now how much canada will cost you
five grand ten grand depending on where
you are this is a forty thousand dollar
model but you keep it forever
oh oh do it again do it again
make the eyes closed i love that there's
a 40
000 model real to life
specifications with muscles bones fibers
it feels like humans or as
laurie says chicken and they're excited
that the eyelids close with a little
clunking sound
i feel like that's a feature him and his
buddies put in like yo let's get it to
move
i'm in i'm sold i want it hello hi my
name is brandon mars
hey brandon mars this is my dad keith
hey keith we're here today to talk about
something that
nobody likes to do what is one thing
that nobody likes to do
go to the dmv clean study airport
security
with the tsa people like going through
airport security do
they yeah cause it's like a maze swallow
pills
what we all like the benefits we get
from vitamins and supplements
but did you know that over a hundred
million people in the united states
alone
cannot or have difficulty swallowing
pills what's worse
they might not even work if you took a
vitamin b or a vitamin c pill
it may look like it's the size of
pittsburgh you may only absorb ten or
twenty percent of it
as a father of two boys okay i'm already
about to be out
simply because of the names of the
sprays kids spray what is like to keep
kids away slim spray are you gonna get
slim
spraying that sea spray is our
multivitamin immunity blend which has as
much vitamin c as 114 oranges
do you really need 114 oranges worth of
vitamin c i want you to think
of supplements as construction materials
imagine you're building a building
and all of a sudden you're getting all
the supplies at the right rate
everything's fine you're building the
building you're on schedule
and then all of a sudden the
manufacturer ships you extra supplies
and
expects you to finish the job sooner
would you be able to do that
no why rate limiting step actually
building the building doesn't matter
that you have more supplies than you
need
same goes with vitamins reboot is our
energy spray which has a mega dose of
vitamin b12
oh well a mega dose
it doesn't it gives you energy because
it probably has caffeine in it vitamin c
you know it's good for supporting your
immune system if you've taken vitamin c
pills or powders for
any of these benefits then get ready
because the next evolution of vitamin c
is here and it's as simple as
spray spray sea spray daily immune
system support wow that was
high budget not bad very good it's
nicely done is it yo check out our
youtube channel guys
for the 100 to 150 million people that
can't swallow pills
are they really saying that half of the
u.s population can't swallow pills
i prescribe pills all the time in my
practice
yes occasionally someone will say hey
doc can you give me uh the liquid
formulation instead but that's a rare
instance
i think you took a different spray than
i did you seem very irritable about this
it's a scam i mean it's a hustle
right wait a second supplement markets
exactly mark calling them out mr
wonderful saying the entire supplement
industry
is a scam i'm on board with these guys
and on that note the dr shark is out
yes my name is lainey lazari i'm from
pittsburgh pennsylvania
and my company is simple sugars is it
just me or does her dress
look like a cake like it has frosting on
it
it has layers looks like there's some
berries on it since infancy i've
suffered from horrible eczema i couldn't
find a single product that i could
safely use on my sensitive skin
let alone one that actually smelled good
so as a determined 11 year old i started
doing research and got to work creating
the product i was looking for it's a
shame that doctors weren't looking for
cures for diseases
we should just get 11 year olds to look
for cures all sorts of diseases we would
solve them right away my homemade
creation not only took away my eczema
but it also cleared up my aunt's
psoriasis
soon i was getting requests from my
friends and family to buy my products
i couldn't pass up the opportunity to
become a businesswoman despite the fact
that i wasn't even a teenager yet
simple sugar's products are all natural
sugar scrubs they gently exfoliate
providing deep moisture and complete
skin nourishment in one easy step
i'm curious what's a sugar scrub sugar
is a molecule that on its own is rough
and crystallized
and exfoliating in nature does she
repackage
sugar into a different container and
probably she adds a moisturizer or
something
and then call it a scrub the result is
super smooth
great looking skin without using a
laundry list of products exfoliant is
something that is rough
that will take off the superficial layer
of dead skin in certain conditions like
psoriasis you actually have a forming of
several layers of this dead skin
as a result you get plaques with
psoriasis so taking off
gently that outer layer of skin is
actually a good thing in some of these
cases
that's why people do exfoliate they buy
all these different products
and actually some exfoliant products are
really bad for the environment because
they have little plastic beads inside of
them
so having a natural alternative like
sugar could be a great option you said
that it cured your own eczema
and psoriasis it's really hard to be
able to make a claim like that
it's not really hard to make a claim
like that it is illegal to make a claim
like that unless you have some kind of
proof
we don't make any claims about what the
product will do for you what we do talk
a lot about is the benefits of each
individual ingredient which is something
you can say but we can't make any claims
about it curing eczema or psoriasis i
can only speak from my experience
i like the product as long as they're
not making any wild claims
i'm in let's get some sugar exfoliant
fluoride 48 is a 100
all-natural medication that has been
clinically proven
to eliminate the symptoms of the cold
and flu within 48 hours
or your money back come on now
no way she's making that claim is this
allowed in australia
clinically proven or your money back in
two days to get rid of the flu
the flu is not a benign virus influenza
serious
if you ever tested positive for flu a
you will be
on your back wow
i love the difference between the u.s
shark tank and the australian shark tank
in australia wow in the u.s
scam it's a scam it has been clinically
trialled on over 10
000 people with a success rate of over
98.9 percent
come on why did they own it as opposed
to a pharmaceutical company why are
these two random individuals
wow it's not often that people come in
here and say they're gonna cure the
common cold
she said flu she didn't she said flu and
common cold
she didn't even distinguish between the
two viruses she's like it just fixes
everything
your leg hurts two days what is the
product because it smells kind of
unusual
only in australia i love it yeah the
product's 100
natural ingredients so there's garlic uh
there's
um echinacea there's no echinacea in it
it is a connection
vitamin c sorry did my guy
just forget what's in his own miracle
potion
can you imagine i'm selling you this
suit and you're like
so you what's good about this dude i'm
like it's a great suit you're like well
i like the color purple no it's not
really purple
it is purple i'm sorry i just i forgot
that i put my life's work into this suit
what part of the immune system are you
playing with
uh vitamin bs i bet he wished he wore a
tie in that moment like look
i'm really nervous
you see that i bought myself three
seconds we've had a professor from
harvard look at this product in detail
he's been involved for the last four
years he's looking forward to reading a
research plan absolutely
yeah absolutely absolutely that's the
possibility evidence i'll roll over and
say i'm wrong
they're trying to solve a problem that
the entire world
scientific communities trying to solve
because if you truly do solve it
not only are you very wealthy you will
save countless lives
and they thought they did it with
ingredients that they have now
changed remembered forgot i'm out hi
my name is jennifer holland and i'm they
pitched me on this i don't know if i'm
allowed to do this
[Applause]
all right conflict of interest
officially being disclosed i believe
i think it's this product was shipped to
me as a sample and i did use them in my
office
not gonna lie they were pretty awesome
introducing
throat scope illuminated tongue
depressor medical device
throat scope is a one hand operated
device with a light source located
inside the mouth for fast accurate
diagnosis
it's like a first world tongue depressor
that's how i would put it there is
nothing
currently on the market for in-home oral
cavity examination do you know what the
number one used product nowadays for
in-home oral examination
in fact when i was uh on the airplane
when the gentleman went into
anaphylactic shock and i
administered a makeshift epinephrine pen
i actually used my iphone light to
consistently check
his oral airway to make sure it was
still open i don't know if this has
widespread implications or use but
i like it i would use it like if i had
my own practice i'd probably buy it dr
kwashofsky here he's ian check out my
video here where i talk about the harsh
reality of being 800 plus
pounds click here you won't regret it as
always stay happy and healthy